نعم حقيقه وتجد دعم كبير ااا سواء كان من
السياسات السعوديه او كانت من الاتحادات
نفسها اا مثلا في عندنا مثلا طالبات في
الجامعه اا كانوا يذهبوا لي مباريات
يعني مده اسبوعين غياب لانها هي كانت في
مباريات وديه مع الكويت ومع مناطق اخرى
وبالفعل يعني كانت تحفيز جميل يعني حتى
صديقاتها بدوي يسالوها ايش اللي يصير هناك
واصبحت يعني الفكره همم المراه همم لن تقف
عند هذا الحد خصوصا مع تعيين همم اعداد
كبيره من النساء في المراكز القياديه
وتمكين المراه سواء كان رياضيا او همم
اجتماعيا او حتى سياسيا كما شاهدنا في
السنوات الماضيه فاعتقد انه مستقبل هذا
الرياضات النسائيه همم كبيره جدا خصوصا مع
سن القوانين التي تمنع الروش وتمنع
المشكلات اللي ممكن تواجهها المراه
الحقيقه
واسر هي تدفع
ببناتهم همم حصد المنجزات وان شاء الله
يجي يوم نشوف منجز همم السيدات في كره
القدم ان شاء الله يوازي الفوز على
الارجنتين منتخب للنساء اللي فهمته
المنتخب امريكا
حتى على المستوى المحلي يعني ان شاء الله
نطمح انه يكون هناك نوع من المباريات
الوديه بين المناطق داخل المملكه